i realize i'm stumbling as i'm speaking
so
as a result of speaking with sahara
every day
i decided
that i should go back and review
the verbs hi there steve kaufman here
again and uh first of all i want to
review my week
uh my i'm in this uh you know streak
with steve challenge and i'm trying to
maintain my link streak in arabic and
persian so i want to update you on my
activities for the past week remember if
you uh enjoy these videos please
subscribe
uh click on the bell for more for
notifications
um you know i'm i'm hoping and i think
the reaction i get from many of my
viewers is that my videos do encourage
them in language learning i think it's
very important for people to be
encouraged
i think the most important role that
anyone involved in language teaching or
language instruction the most important
role one can have is to
is to trigger
curiosity enthusiasm hunger
the desire to learn that's the absolute
key more important than any explanations
or techniques of learning or anything of
those
of that kind it's to get people
motivated to trigger their enthusiasm
their hunger for learning
so i had my week uh in
persian in farsi in persian
and every day i spoke with my tutor
sahra in iran
who is in the town of rasht in gilan
province in
northern iran and she showed me some
pictures from there and it looks
semi-tropical uh quite unlike the image
that we normally have of iran as sort of
a very you know dry climate
and
i certainly feel that i spoke a lot
better at the end of the week than i did
at the beginning of the week
i try to start my day with 13 my you
know obligatory obligatory sort of
minimal goal of 13 links created in each
of arabic and and persian so i do that
get that out of the way
that's my sort of duty
uh
and i did again a lot of listening and
reading but
in particular as a result of of uh
talking to safra every day for an hour
of course i realized where my gaps are
and the biggest problem i have is with
verbs of course i'm missing a lot of
vocabulary but
i'll i'll you know acquire those over
time
i'm often missing some of the most basic
items of vocabulary which i've forgotten
which i once knew
and as i said in one of my tweets i'm
always impressed
with how easy it is to forget even the
most basic
you know words in the language and yet
here we are i'm speaking with sarah we
have a conversation so some words do
stick but some words when i need them i
can't find them that's absolutely normal
and but what i find is that verbs give
me trouble and i think that's true in a
lot of languages that's why our many
stories that link focus on the most you
know common verbs in the language the
highest frequency verbs for
comprehension of course we're always
going to miss some key nouns but when we
go to speak i find that if i can't
do well on the verbs i have a lot of
trouble expressing myself and
when i was you know speaking with her i
realized that i was for example in in
persian there's a subjunctive and when
do you actually use the subjunctive and
and uh there are different tenses and
and in the spoken form of the language
there's no future so it seems strange
that we're using the present tense for
the future tense and there are many
things like that that i realize i'm
stumbling as i'm speaking
so
as a result of speaking with sahara
every day
i decided
that i should go back and review
the verbs
which and i've read this book many times
and you know it just has 100 the most i
probably can't see these two are all
about the highest frequency verbs in all
the different forms and i just kind of
leave through it i go jump around look
up different verbs
the other thing i did was
i did a lot of listening to the mini
stories where i know
you know
i wouldn't say all but a lot of the
vocabulary but the many stories are
based on the most frequently used verbs
and there you know the story might have
one
story in one tense and another story in
another tense or another person so
this is a great way to review the verbs
and i think this is again an important
point you know i've often said in some
of my other videos that you can't master
the basics we're constantly looping back
to do the basics again i've listened to
the many stories 30 40 50 times and i
discover something new every time i
listen so
to me language learning is a matter of
constantly looping back we push forward
into new content
uh in order to acquire more vocabulary
but at the same improve our
comprehension but at the same time in
order to be able to talk we have to be
able to use the word the verbs rather
and so i go back to the many stories and
there's this constant looping back and
then charging forward and of course it
helps to have a great tutor
that you know triggers that enthusiasm
that hunger
uh
gets you going
uh which is the case with sahara and i
never have to think of what i'm gonna
say because she constantly asks me
questions keeps me going i don't have to
worry what are we gonna talk about
that's her problem not my problem and i
know that she will get me talking
and she's a wonderful tutor because she
not only has created content for us at
link
uh on the history of iran on cuisine of
iran on so many different things right
now she's done one on the
famous iranian movie directors and she's
even found
she sent me a 30-minute
sound file from one of the famous move
farhadi is a famous director and he has
this movie called the salesman
um
for furugor maybe forus hyundai i don't
remember
uh i don't worry about what i can't
remember and uh
photoshonde i think it is but but so
then the sound file is so full of car
noises and door slamming and other
miscellaneous noises that it's not great
listening all by itself because it's not
sufficiently word rich and i think this
is often the case with movies movies
again stimulate you they create that
hunger you want to learn the language
i'm enjoying watching danish you know
the body hotel
but in terms of really working on either
verbs or increasing your vocabulary uh i
find that the audio content that's
richer you know denser in terms of words
is more effective anyway that's what
i've been doing so i wanted to update
you on my week two of my challenge
i think i'm keeping up with my streak
it's a low bar 13 links created every
day
typically i'm creating if it's the
language that i'm on for that week i'm
creating you know 50 60 at least
next week i'm into arabic
and i'm hoping to be talking every day
with muhammad
i sometimes get very kind offers from
people
who say they'll help me in my persian or
my arabic
right now i'm kind of committed to those
tutors
and don't have a lot of time to get
involved with other people in those
languages because i also have other
things to do the last two days i played
golf with with my wife and we did a lot
of cleaning up after our renovations in
the kitchen so there's always lots of
stuff to do but i have my routine in
persian and arabic and that's what i'm
kind of sticking to